مساء الخير؛
يحتوي ديوان المثنوي لجلال الدين الرومي،
على 25632 بيتاً من الشعر،
وفيه 424 قصة تسرد معاناة الإنسان للوصول إلى حبّه في السماء.
و كما سبق أن أشرنا،
حمل  الكتاب اسم  "المثنوي"،
نسبة إلى الوزن العروضي الخاص المستعمَل في نظمه،
ويتألف من أبيات مفردة مقسمة على شطرين مقفَّيين،
وبذلك يتحرر الشاعر من وحدة القافية فى القصيدة.
جلال الدين الرومي كان يشكو من الشعر المقفّى بشكله التقليدي،
لأنه يقيِّده ويحدُّ من حريته في التعبير عمّا يريد؛
فكان يقول؛
"إنني أفكر في القافية،
ويقول حبيبي لا تفكر إلاَّ في لقائي،
مستفعلن مستفعلن قتلتني."
قسَّمَ جلال الدين الرومي كتابه المثنوي إلي ستة أجزاء،
وكل جزء له مقدِّمة خاصّة.
من بين هذه المقدِّمات الست،
ثلاثٌ باللغة العربية،
وهي مقدِّمات الأجزاء؛
الأول والثالث والرابع،
والأخريات باللغة الفارسية.
يقول في مقدِّمة الجزء الأول، وهي مقدِّمة الكتاب كله:
"هذا كتاب المثنوي،
وهو أصول أصول أصول الدين،
في كشف أسرار الوصول واليقين،
وهو فقه الله الأكبر،
وشرع الله الأزهر،
وبرهان الله الأظهر،
مَثَلُ نُورِهِ كمشكاة فيها مصباح،
يشرق إشراقًا أَنْوَرَ من الإصباح،
وهو جِنان الجَنان،
ذوات العيون والأغصان،
منها عين تُسَمَّى عند أبناء هذا السبيل سلسبيلَا،
وعند أصحاب المقامات والكرامات خيرٌ مقامًا وأحسن مقيلَا.
الأبرار فيه يأكلون ويشربون،
والأحرار منه يفرحون ويطربون،
وهو كنيل مصر شرابٌ للصابرين،
وحسرة على آل فرعون والكافرين،
كما قال الله تعالى:
يُضِلُّ بِهِ كَثِيرًا وَيَهْدِي بِهِ كَثِيرًا وَمَا يُضِلُّ بِهِ إِلَّا الْفَاسِقِينَ.
وإنه شفاء الصدور،
وجلاء الأحزان،
وكشَّاف القرآن،
وسعةُ الأرزاق،
وتطييبُ الأخلاق بأيدي سَفَرةٍ، كرام برَرَة،
يمنعون بألَّا يمسَّه إلا المطهرون،
تنزيلٌ من رب العالمين،
لَّا يَأْتِيهِ الْبَاطِلُ مِن بَيْنِ يَدَيْهِ وَلَا مِنْ خَلْفِهِ،
والله يرصده ويرقبه،
وهو خيرٌ حافظًا وهو أرحم الراحمين،
وله ألقاب أُخَرَ لقَّبه الله تعالى بها،
واقتصرنا على هذا القليل،
والقليلُ يدل على الكثير،
والجرعة تدل على الغدير،
والحفنة تدل على البيدر الكبير".
نلاحظ في هذه المقدِّمة،
الحضور المكثّف للنص القرآني،
وهذا الحضور،
سيتواصل في كل ديوان المثنوي من خلال المجاز اللغوي أو القصص القرآنيين.
يسكن مثنوي الرومي النص القرآني،
كنص مؤسس للحضارة العربية الإسلامية،
لذلك سمّى الشاعر الفارسي عبد الرحمن الجامي
ديوان المثنوي بالقرآن الفارسي،
وقال:
"إن جلال الدين الرومي لم يكن نبيا، ولكنه أوتي كتابا".
بعد المقدِّمة،
يفتتح جلال الدين الرومي ديوانه بقصيدة أنين الناي،
ويبدأها بفعل الأمر أَنصت،
كما بدأ النص القرآني بفعل الأمر اقرأ.
يقول جلال الدين الرومي :
أنصت،
أنصت إلى الناي يحكي حكايته...
ومن ألم الفراق يبث شكايته...
منذ قُطعت من الغاب،
والرجال والنساء لأنيني يبكون...
أريد صدراً مِزَقاً مِزَقا،
برَّحه الفراق...
لأبوح له بألم الاشتياق...
فكل من قُطع عن أصله،
دائماً يحن إلى زمان وصله...
وهكذا غدوت مطرباً في المحافل...
أشدو للسعداء،
وأنوح للبائسين...
وكلٌ يظن أنني له رفيق...
ولكن،
أياً منهم،
السعداء والبائسين،
لم يدرك حقيقة ما أنا فيه...
لم يكن سري بعيداً عن نُواحي...
ولكن أين هي الأذن الواعية، والعين المبصرة؟
فالجسم مشتبك بالروح،
والروح متغلغلة في الجسم...
ولكن،
أنّى لإنسان أن يبصر تلك الروح؟
أنين الناي،
نار لا هواء...
فلا كان من لم تضطرب في قلبه النار...
نار الناي،
هي سورة الخمر،
وحمّى العشق...
وهكذا كان الناي صديق من بان...
وهكذا مزّقت ألحانه الحجب عن أعيننا...
فمن رأى مثل الناي سماً وترياقاً؟
ومن رأى مثل الناي خليلاً مشتاقاً؟
إنه يقص علينا حكايات الطريق،
التي خضبتها الدماء...
ويروي لنا أحاديث العشق المجنون...
الحكمة التي يرويها،
محرمة على الذين لا يعقِلون...
إذ لا يشتري عذب الحديث،
غير الأذن الواعية...
في قصيدته أنين الناي،
يتحدث جلال الدين الرومي،
عن شوق الانسان إلى اصله الالهي،
والناي هنا،
يرمز إلى النفس البشرية،
وكيف انها  فى حنين دائم إلى عالمها الأوّل،
مثل حنين الناي إلى منبته الذي اُقتلع منه.
جلال الدين الرومي
يوازي
بين النفخ في الناي،
وبين النفخة الإلهية الأولى التي منحت الحياة لآدم،
استنادا
إلى النص القرآنى القائل؛
"فَإِذَا سَوَّيْتُهُ وَنَفَخْتُ فِيهِ مِن رُّوحِي".
استمعو إلى بعض الأبيات من قصيدة أنين الناي،
بصوت الفنان المبدع أحمد حويلي...
بالنسبة إلى جلال الدين الرومي كل ما في الوجود يعزف موسيقى؛
خفقات القلب،
ورفرفة أجنحة الطير،
هبوب الريح في ليلة عاصفة.
يتساءل الرومي،
محاججا الفقهاء الذين حرّموا سماع الموسيقى فيقول:
كيف،
لله أن يخلق الموسيقى التي تغلف كل أشكال الحياة،
ثم يحرّم علينا  ان نسمعها؟
الطبيعة برمتها تغني،
كل شيء في هذا الكون يتحرك بإيقاع.
في حين يعتبر الفقهاء أن الموسيقى هي صوت صرير أبواب جهنّم،
يرى جلال الدين الرومي أن الموسيقى هي صوت أزيز أبواب الجنّة.
جلال الدين الرومي
يعانق فكرة  الفيلسوف وعالم الموسيقى أبو نصر الفارابي،
عندما قال؛
إن هناك صلة بين فطرة الإنسان والموسيقى،
ووجود الموسيقى معلول من ذات الإنسان.
الموسيقى عند جلال الدين الرومي
هي جزء من فلسفة السماع،
التي تشمل الرقص كذلك،
هذه الفلسفة الذوقية،
تسعى لتأسيس منهج ذوقي جديد للمسلم
يختلف عن الموقف الفقهي الرسمي الرافض للموسيقى والرقص.
فالإمام الشافعي مثلا
أفتى بعدم جواز شهادة من اتّخذ من الغناء صناعة،
وشبّه الغناء باللهو المكروه الذي يشبه الباطل.
ويذهب الحنابلة
إلى القول بأنه لا يحل شيء من العود والزمر والطبل  والرباب ونحو ذلك...
تحدّثت المستشرقة الفرنسية إيفا ميروفيتش
في كتابها، الرّومي والتصوّف،
عن رقصة السماع
التي وضع أسسها جلال الدين الرومي بمعية شيخه شمس التبريزي،
وحدّد نواميسها ابنه مؤسس الطريقة المولوية سلطان ولد، فقالت؛
ويُعَد السماع،
أو الرقص الكوني للدراويش الدوَّارين،
من أشهر فنون الطريقة المولوية.
وهو طقس له رمزيته؛
فالثياب البيضاء
التي يرتديها الراقصون ترمز إلى الكفن؛
والمعاطف السوداء
ترمز إلى القبر؛
وقلنسوة اللبّاد ترمز إلى شاهد القبر؛
والبساط الأحمر
يرمز إلى لون الشمس الغاربة؛
والدورات الثلاث حول باحة الرقص
ترمز إلى الأشواط الثلاثة في التقرب إلى الله،
وهي:
طريق العلم،
والطريق إلى الرؤية،
والطريق إلى الوصال؛
وسقوط المعاطف السوداء يعني الخلاص والتطهر من الدنيا؛
وتذكِّر الطبول بالنفخ في الصُّور يوم القيامة؛
ودائرة الراقصين تُقسَم على نصفَي دائرة،
يمثل أحدهما قوس النزول أو انغماس الروح في المادة،
ويمثل الآخر قوس الصعود أي صعود الروح إلى بارئها؛
ويمثل دوران الشيخ حول مركز الدائرة الشمس وشعاعها؛
أما حركة الدراويش حول الباحة،
فتمثل القانون الكوني ودوران الكواكب حول الشمس وحول مركزها.
جلال الدين الرومي،
كتب قبل وفاته، موجّها خطابه لمن يأتي لزيارة قبره فقال:
عندما تأتي لزيارة قبري،
سيظهر لك قبري المسقوفُ راقصا،
لا تأت من دون دف إلى قبري،
أي أخي!
لأن من استبد به الحزن لا يليق بمائدة الحق!
إذن الرومي يُجلس الموسيقى والرقص حول مائدة الحق.
المستشرقة الألمانية آن ماري شيمل، في كتابها الشمس المنتصرة،
تبين التأثير الكبير لشاعرين صوفيين على جلال الدين الرومي،
الأوّل هو الشاعر الفارسي السنائي الغزوي،
صاحب منظومة حديقة الحقيقة،
ولد سنة 1080 ميلادية وتوفي 1150 ميلادية بمدينة غزنة في أفغانستان اليوم،
أما الثاني فهو فريد الدين العطّار صاحب كتاب "منطق الطير"،
والذي ولد سنة 1146 ميلادية وتوفي سنة 1221 ميلادية في مدينة نيسابور.
قال الرومي متحدثا عن هذين الشاعرين الكبيرين؛
كان العطّار روح التصوّف و السنائي عينيه وقد جئنا بعد السنائي والعطار.
واذا كان الحبّ هو محور التصوّف العربي،
فإن العشق سيكون محور التصوّف الفارسي.
التصوّف العربي،
سوف يجعل من الآية القائلة؛
"يحبّهم ويحبّونه"، أساس العلاقة بين الإنسان وخالقه،
في حين سوف يرتقي التصوّف الفارسي
بهذه العلاقة إلى مرتبة العشق.
يعرّف ابن منظور العشق؛ فيقول:
هو فَرْطُ الحب،
ويضيف؛
سُئِلَ أبو العبَّاسِ أحمد بن يحيى النحوي عن الحُبِّ والعِشقِ: أيُّهُمَا أحْمَدُ؟
فقال: الحب؛
لأنَّ العشقَ فيه إفراط،
وسُمِّيَ العاشِقُ عاشقًا؛
لأنَّه يذْبُلُ من شدِّةِ الهَوَى كما تذبلُ العَشَقَةُ،
والعشقة شجرة تخضرُّ ثم تَدِقُّ وتَصْفَرُّ إذا قُطِعَت.
أبو الطيب المتنبّي الذي كان ديوانه لا يفارق الرومي تحدّث عن العشق فقال؛
وعذلْتُ أهلَ العِشقِ حَتّى ذُقتُهُ
فعجِبتُ كَيفَ يَمُوتُ مَنْ لا يعشَقُ
وعذَرتهمْ وعرفتُ ذنبيَ أنّنِي
عيّرتُهم
فَلَقِيتُ فِيهِ ما لقُوا.
أمّا المتصوّف الفارسي الشهير نجم الدين كبرى،
فيقول؛
نِهَايَاتُ المَحَبَّةِ، هي بِدَايَاتُ العِشْقِ،
وجلال الدين الرومي بعدهما يقول؛
العشق نار تَحْرِق كلَّ ما سوى المحبوب.
يقيم جلال الدين الرومي في ديوان  المثنوي،
حوارا بين العقل والعشق:
يقول العقل:
" الجهات الستّ هي الحدّ وليس ثمة طريق إلى للخارج"
ويردّ العشق:
" هناك طريق آخر لا تعرفه وقد مشيته مرّات".
الجهات الست عند العقل كما يحددها الفلاسفة هي؛
الشرق والغرب، والشمال، والجنوب، والفوق، والتحت،
ولكن العشق يضيف بعدا سابعا يجهله العقل.
يصف الرومي مدرسة العشق المحظورة على الفقهاء والفلاسفة والأطباء والمنجمين
بمدرسة العلم اللّدُنّي،
العلم الإلهي المباشر دون مدرسة وورق،
المدرسة المصنوعة من النار والتي ينبغي على التلميذ أن يجلس فيها وينضج.
ونار العشق بالنسبة إليه خير من ماء الحياة.
يشبه الرومي العقل بساق من خشب،
تمكّنك من المشي ولكن لا تمضي بها بعيدا،
لا يستطيع الإنسان في تقديره أن يجتاز البحر الناري للعشق بالساق الخشبية للعقل.
هذا النقد اللاذع لجلال الدين الرومي للعقل،
هو في الحقيقة نقد لنظرية المعرفة عند الفلاسفة،
الذين يعتبرون الحقيقة العقلية المنطقية هي أرقى أشكال الحقيقة،
ويحطّون من شأن الحقيقة العرفانيّة.
الفيلسوف فخر الدين الرازيُّ مثلا،
يرى ان العشق مرضٌ روحانيٌّ غليظٌ، يشوِّه النَّفس الإنسانيَّة تشوُّهًا مَمْقُوتًا.
وابن سينا الفيلسوف والطبيب،
اعتبر العشق ضمن أمراض الدماغ،
وقال عنه إنه مرض وسواسي شبيه بالماليخوليا،
والماليخوليا كما عرَّفَهَا هي تغيّر الظنون والفكر عَن المجرى الطبيعي إِلَى الْفساد،
وَإِلَى الْخَوْف والرداءة لمزاج سوداوي،
يوحش روح الدِّمَاغ من دَاخله ويفزعه بظلمته.
جلال الدين الرومي سيؤسس لفلسفة العشق على نقيض فلسفة العقل،
ويرى أن قلب عشقانا خير من ألف عقل يقظان،
ويتغنى بالعشق قائلا:
العشق يدخل في عيني الأعمى، فيعطيه نظرا.
ويدخل في فم الأبكم، فيُصيّر له لسانا.
ويدخل في الشيطان القبيح الوجه فيجعله في جمال يوسف.
ويدخل في صورة الذئب فيصيّره راعيا.
في ديوان المثنوي نجد 424 قصّة،
اقتبسها جلال الدين الرومي من مؤلف كليلة ودمنة،
ومن عدة أمثولات هندية وفارسية وبيزنطية،
وقام بادخال بعض التعديلات على عناصرها لتبليغ حِكمه للقارئ،
أذكر منها قصة "الفيل في الظلام"،
وقد أخذها من أمثولة هندية تحمل اسم "الفيل و العميان"،
وتتحدث عن فيل،
نقلهُ هنود من بلدة إلى أخرى،
وعند وصوله في الليل وضعوه في حظيرة،
وتسلل الناسُ إلى الحظيرة في الظلام الدامس،
وأخذ كلُّ إنسانٍ يتحسس الفيل،
فالذي وجد الخرطوم قال إنّ الفيل إنما هو خرطوم ماء،
وقال من لمس ظهره أنه يشبه السرير،
وقال من لمس الأذن انه يشبه المروحة،
وهكذا فكلُّ واحد ممن لمس الفيل،
ظنَّ أن ما لمسه هو كمالُ خلقة الفيل،
بينما لم يشعر كل واحد منهم إلا بجزء صغير من الفيل.
ويستنتج الرومي،
ان هذا هو حال المتعصّبين من الديانات،
الذين لمسوا من الحقيقة شيئًا ضئيلاً جدًا ظنوه كل الحقيقة.
يقول جلال الدين الرومي؛
«الحقيقة.. مرآة،
ألقى بها الرّحمان إلى عباده فتشظّت،
وحظي كلّ منهم بجزء منها معتقدا أنّه الكلّ».
أشكركم على المتابعة،
أعود لكم في الحلقة القادمة ومعي قواعد العشق الأربعون،
رحيق فلسفة العشق عند جلال الدين الرومي وشيخه شمس الدين التبريزي،
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في القناة وتفعيل الجرس ليصلكم كل جديد.
هذا نجيب البكوشي من باريس،
دمتم بخير وإلى لقاء قريب.